I love the facilities here I'm here like
every day this pool is just a monument
to swimming it's big it's nice that you
can have the 50 meters in the summer my
kids take swimming lessons here and then
I played water polo here the health and
fitness level of the whole campus has
changed I take PE classes usually in the
morning so it's a great way to start my
day I just start off really energized
and focused and ready to learn
I was one of the sets of people to get a
MIT pirate certificate can you take
archery sailing fencing and pistol Holly
mateys
I'm from Minnesota but actually never
skated before coming here so I will not
escape
it's really just my way of dealing with
stress from the day it's coming either
here and working out or doing my club
sport
visualize your heartbeat slowing it's
all about stillness in being able to
break the perfect shot without
disturbing the sight alignment sight
picture and that takes unbelievable
amount of control MIT students tend to
be very busy and to forget about their
health by opening the Z Center a lot of
these students stay in shape hang out
have a great time here so it's not a
one-dimensional school
bringing the Z Center to MIT really
helped us turn the corner
several of our teams have gone on to
compete in the NCAA at the national
level and have been successful that all
comes from being able to attract really
top level student-athletes this win
requirement could be satisfied by this
beginning swim class or you can elect to
test out that ability to swim is a good
skill to have I mean one never knows
when they're going to be in a situation
where it's going to be valuable where it
may be a life-saving thing for them
you should have left this club when you
go back I have a launch monitor which
gets Golf Club information golf ball
information I have a 3d dolphin analyzer
it's a real pleasure to have this a
teacher I'm pretty lucky there's not
many people around who have this good of
a system when you are doing what you
really love to do and if you get really
good at it then